day night the general election
campaigning it seems everybody loves a
bit of nostalgia including the Labour
Party who brought Tony Blair back into
the campaign today speaking from
sedgefield professing one hundred
percent support for ed Miliband which is
more than he would have got from some of
his interviews over the past few months
will it move a single vote for ed
Miliband that protestation well it may
cost a few votes in places like Scotland
where Tony Blair was less popular shall
we say and there's a debate there
tonight expect him to come up but
there's no doubting it he won three
general election majorities including
that things over there of batter seen
three times it was won by labour under
tony blair's leadership and yet now it's
6,000 majority for the Conservatives can
ed miliband reach those parts that sony
blended sony best fish mainly about
Europe a warning about a referendum and
the David Cameron that is the reason why
he says he's backing Ed Miliband because
there will be no referendum